live now to franco fratini the former
foreign minister of italy and current
vice president of the eu commission on
security and immigration franco thank
you very much for joining us on rt uh i
want to talk about of course these talks
i mean with most regional actors taking
part do you think that this is going to
help
powers find common ground on regional
security issues
well it's absolutely necessary i would
say is badly needed
to have
an inclusive process
of discussion
among all the components of the afghan
society and what is moscow is doing is
extremely important personally i don't
trust
talibans because uh talibans have proven
to be uh rarely keeping their promises
also because
they are divided
from inside because some factions are
more extremists some other factions
would be in favor of an inclusive
government but the exercise is of great
help
provided that the taliban accept for
example the tajiki component that used
becky component the other components
other than pashtun take part of an
inclusive government in the near future
in afghanistan
well franco i wanted to ask you about uh
something the taliban said they warned
that the continuation of sanctions will
result in a wave of refugees would you
say this is something akin to a warning
or a threat
uh both
it can be also a threat because uh it is
true the talibans have said at the very
beginning they will be prohibiting the
afghans to leave the country but as i
said before uh very often they don't
keep
what they have declared in this case it
is for sure rewarding uh be careful
because of the sanctions based policy
the results can be i would say
a wave of people
flows of people leaving the country so
it can be
necessary to take into consideration the
possibility that at a certain moment
taliban decide to open the doors of the
country in order to put under
heavy pressure the west and the
bordering countries
well say that possibility you just
mentioned there becomes a reality
western countries have previously
demanded that the taliban respect
people's right to leave afghanistan does
that mean that the west is ready for an
influx of refugees do you think
uh
absolutely not not ready yet
i see a difficulty in this case
i remember very well
the flows of refugees coming from syria
partially hosted
in turkey some arriving to the
european shores this is a quite
difficult situation because a person
leaving afghanistan had to go through
the most dangerous regions in the world
the whole of middle east countries where
it's very difficult to stay and to
travel
before arriving to european
proximity regions but nevertheless
europe should be ready should be ready
should be well prepared now
because we are talking not about
economic migrants we are talking about
women children and men
trying to take refuge like trying to
escape
from
serious violations of their fundamental
rights so the typical status of refugees
contemplated by the european and
international conventions so europe
please be ready don't do what has been
done during the iraqi crisis many years
ago and what has been doing during the
syrian crisis more recently
well i think it's also important to note
also that as these talks are going on in
moscow russia has closed its nato office
after the expulsion of its diplomats how
do you think that is going to play on
the success or failure of these uh talks
going on right now
well it doesn't help
i was the one
that
years ago but not a century ago just at
the beginning of 2000 in 2002 signed the
agreement in rome between nato and
russia in order to open a possibility to
have a consultation even a cooperation
between nato and russia now
when it comes to the recent events
these are deteriorating the
atmosphere and are increasing the
feeling of mutual mistrust this for sure
doesn't help in any case not only on
afghanistan but on addressing the other
pressing crisis from mediterranean to
syria to libya and others
well at the same time also we have this
gas crisis going on i mean despite
russia fulfilling its contractual
obligations with europe something that
high-profile figure figures like angela
merkel have confirmed uh we continue to
hear from the western media about uh
moscow somehow being to blame for this
crisis why do you think that is
uh well i i i think simply there is no
doubt
in in certain uh western newspapers not
in old newspapers fortunately
some
anti-russia
feeling and some anti-russian propaganda
i've i've seen i've heard
president putin clarifying this point by
saying we are increasing energy supply
not decreasing energy supply this is
absolutely a matter of fact but
nevertheless unfortunately some
propaganda some fake news are
aggravating a situation in a field the
one of energy security where we need
more cooperation with the russian
federation i hope that the new
government of germany will follow the
same path of chancellor merkel on that
i would say
criticizing our partners when necessary
but cooperating when needed
and staying on that uh that theme just
one more question for you franco do you
think europe will be able to resolve
this uh this energy crisis before uh
winter sets in and what should be done
in your opinion
uh well um i i've been
always a partisan
of more cohesion and more integration in
the field of energy security among the
european member states unfortunately
there are some european member states
that i would say
prefer
to keep very high
the level of tension against russian
federation instead of
cooperating and trying to
creating a bridge between europe and
russia italy is one of the exceptions of
this entire russia feeling you know that
just yesterday
my prime minister president draghi had
the third
phone call in only three months with
president putin in view of the g20
presidency this is a sign that italy
considers russia an interlocutor and
an important actor well when addressing
global issues like the one we are
talking about
franco fertini former foreign minister
of italy and the vice president for the
u commission on security and immigration
thanks a lot for joining us